this is Jocko underground podcast number
54 Echo Charles sitting here with me
this is actually
you're for some reason you want you were
asking about this this topic of the day
the topic is Alpha
beta gamma I think gamma Omega Delta and
sigma
humans
male female
uh had you ever heard I think you
mentioned to me you you saw online or
something you were reading about the
sigma male is this Sigma is like the new
one right that's what I thought at the
time yes so
I didn't really know too much about the
sigma of course you all everyone hears
you know the alpha everyone hears that
uh
so you just say hey what what are these
things
so I figured we'd look into them a
little bit uh the term
these terms were almost solely used to
describe animals up until the 1990s so
there was back in the day they didn't
they didn't use these and there's a book
came out in 1982 called chimpanzee
politics by Franz de wall which
suggested that
maybe some of these
categories could be applied to human
beings and then in the 1990s and this is
from Wikipedia
so take that for what it's worth
Dove deep on the research and plugged it
into Wikipedia see what we get 1990s
term used to describe quote manly men
that are successful in business and and
then there's of course a whole thing
about these same terms you to describe
females so
I had heard of alpha I had heard of beta
I hadn't heard of gamma I hadn't heard
of Omega I hadn't heard of Delta and I
you kind of chimed me in on the whole
Sigma phenomenon you think the sigma is
is what people want to be
or does everyone just want to be Alpha I
feel like at the end of the day and
you'll go into what each one is is I
feel like everyone wants to be Alpha but
like a um like an introvert you know
Alpha is like he'll take charge he'll
make calls he'll talk to anybody
whatever the sigma is like he's
introvert and shy and stuff and then so
it he kind of I don't know like kind of
Embraces that whole thing kind of like a
quiet freaking all right so Alpha here's
some descriptions Alpha is supposed to
be dominating and charismatic the porn
leader understands his priorities and
utilizes and it always utilizing his
time that's the alpha
the beta is modest and easy going Ideal
Husband type
works a lot but is over showered by
overshadowed by his peers the gamma
is introverted and super sensitive
I don't think I fall in the category of
super sense super insensitive uh the Yes
man at the office is the gamma
has big plans but lacks determination
and focus gamma hmm
next one is Omega look there's a movie
called Omega Man I wonder why it's
called that Omega Man yeah
this person is skillful and
self-sufficient the odd one in the uh in
the wolf pack laid back not chasing
success or money
so like The Artsy type or something I
don't know that's what it sounds like
actually they don't even really talk
about that they don't even talk about
like which one of these has some
creative aspect to them as opposed to
like the big five which is
open-mindedness and those people tend to
be more creative
next one is Delta modest and hardworking
wants attention but can't get it
works hard but unable to draw attention
and then the sigma this is the latest
and greatest Edition
super smart and extremely attractive
the manipulative Mastermind
he is super ambitious ambitious and his
own boss
so
there you go dude I don't even know like
do we even need to go any further on
these things because it's like just some
basic kind of personality stereotypes
right isn't that basically what they are
yeah just some basic stereotypes and
then
that's that yeah and a lot of times too
kind of similar to like a horoscope kind
of scenario where you know people wanna
I feel like that I don't know maybe I'm
just thinking about this for myself no
no but every once in a while where you
like you'll fall into and you wonder
what what given these this category or
this this criteria like who am I right
then you kind of look at it and eat if I
have a cool name Alpha Beta Gama gamma
doesn't sound cool I don't know why
right but do you think beta sounds cool
actually I had a fish called a big you
know buddies you actually have a name
Echo
but Sigma sounds cool Delta sounds cool
Omega sounds cool
um I guess beta cam it doesn't sound
that cool that's just my opinion Alpha
of course okay so you're just going on
name yeah you know but I'm saying like
hey yeah I'm a Delta you know it's like
you
I don't know if this is a natural thing
maybe maybe not but you know how like
people who are into uh astrology or
whatever their horoscope they're like
yeah I'm a Sagittarius so therefore I
this and that or you're he's a Leo so
this and you know
it's I think some at some level yeah I
don't know it feels good to be like in a
sort of category well yeah I mean that's
why like people do their genetic test
and they're like I am a Native American
and they're like point zero or like I'm
Viking or whatever like they're they do
that they're like kind of yeah hey I'm
Scott's Irish I was you know a
Highlander like people people get into
that kind of stuff and yeah like maybe
it's because uh this will just pops up
you've seen it in that voice made me uh
kind of think of like oh yeah like if
this can't Alpha okay not alpha alpha is
like obvious but let's say Sigma for
example right it's like hell yeah that's
a cool name for that kind of person and
then it's like yeah I'm a sigma I'm
super smart I'm extremely attractive uh
I'm a mastermind that can be
manipulative yeah you know yeah you know
what's you know what people start to try
and fulfill the prophecy right a little
bit like oh I'm an alpha like a woman
could dominate this room yeah and
there's no one that's like hey I'm gonna
be more beta in fact they're running
away from beta they're like wait a
second Abate is modest I'm not gonna be
that I'm not gonna be a bait I'm gonna
be hey what's up yeah uh the sigma since
I didn't I pulled some traits for the
sigma male
says he loves being alone but he values
other people
he's a silent leader what's interesting
about that is I talk a lot about being a
silent leader as a goal yeah
because if you're doing everything right
as a leader you shouldn't have to say
too much and the team's already getting
it done yeah call that the silent leader
this is a little bit different but yeah
this is more like a personality thing
more so than a leading uh he knows how
to adapt to different situations he
treats everyone around I think this is
the selling they're selling the sigma on
this one yeah is this is the sigma male
the person that's not quite Alpha but
then they're kind of coming up with
their own thing that's what it felt like
to me and keep in mind
read about this I watched YouTube videos
it kept popping up about this Sigma male
and you know once you click on one you
see he treats everyone around him the
same way he doesn't need a Social Circle
to be himself yeah these are all super
affirming right he understands the
importance of Silence
he is morally gray or Worse that's a
little bit of a negative right he hates
living safely
Adventurer his social skills could use
some work
he's incredibly softball because this is
not all positive but you know what that
gives a little bit let's say you're
socially awkward and you're trying to
buy into this you're like well you know
I'm kind of I'm more of a sigma that's
what I thought that's why I'm super
awkward or like you know how like okay
so you know public speaking for example
or speaking in large groups or whatever
it's like a
anxiety-inducing thing for a lot of
people so that's like you know the alpha
would never say that right yeah I don't
talk to anybody but man sometimes it's
like man you kind of can't help it so
it's like hey instead of just saying I'm
awful well I just say I'm a sigma yeah
same scene yeah like I it's like it's on
purpose in front of crowds yeah I'm not
worried about that because I'm
incredibly self-aware which is another
thing and I'm a master of my own fate
which is another thing and I could be an
alpha if I wanted to that's the last
thing it says he could be an alpha if he
wanted that's what it felt like it
sounds like someone created Sigma
recently I should do a little more
research and find out who created Sigma
it's probably some dude that's a little
bit shy yeah that feels a little bit
insecure that he knows he can't just say
I'm a alpha so he just made up this
other thing over here called the sigma
the sigma male
um so like I said man as far as I'm
concerned these are just basically a
bunch of stereotypes on how much time we
don't want to waste on this but uh
here's one thing that I will take away
from this
each one of these things look you could
you could have a bunch of these
different characteristics as one person
and you most likely do right you most
likely have some of these
characteristics from each one of these
categories and I think what the
important thing to do is to I have
talked about this before know what your
Tendencies are
right so know what your Tendencies are
and if you know what your Tendencies are
if you know that you
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
immobilized
Underground